foreign
[Applause]
my goodness thank you so much for coming
this afternoon
um thank you thank you thank you it's
just delightful to see you so what I'm
hoping to do this afternoon is to give a
brief introduction to my latest book the
title is pen theologies it's a word I
made up the subtitle is God's worlds and
monsters
I got the idea for the project while I
was writing about the stories that the
Natural Sciences are currently telling
us beautiful stories of Mythic
proportions about infinite universes
fish that become land creatures photons
that make decisions trees that
communicate rocks that are alive all
these stories are taking on for our
secular world the role that sacred
stories used to play all of them tell us
in different ways where we came from how
things get made and how we ought to
behave in relation to the world that
we're a part of now of course these
scientific stories say they have nothing
to do with religion some of them like
the Multiverse and some forms of
evolution even Proclaim that they
disprove the existence of God but what's
striking to me is that they're not
really getting rid of God at all they're
just reassigning God's major tasks to
the universe itself they're attributing
creation and sustenance and governance
destruction and Redemption all to forces
inside the world rather than a force
outside the world so rather than kicking
God out one might say they're sort of
pulling God all the way in
the philosophical name for this identity
of God and world is pantheism
so I thought this is great I'll write a
book about the unintentional pantheism
of the Natural Sciences
I'll start with a quick conceptual
history of pantheism and then I'll
demonstrate its reappearance in the
natural and social sciences despite the
professed atheism of its authors
the problem was the moment I went to
gather the history of pantheism I found
there is no such history far from being
a coherent school or even a concept
pantheism is really just an accusation
it's just a nasty thing to call an idea
that a philosopher thinks is dangerous
or dumb
so I ended up having to take a step back
and figure out why pantheism is such a
bad word in the western tradition that
made it up I'm going to sketch a bit of
that history here as a way to introduce
the concerns of this book in the first
half of the talk I'll explain what's so
threatening about pantheism and in the
second half I'll try to start
reconstructing it as a concept to ask
what pantheism might actually mean if we
gave it a moment to speak before
laughing it off the stage
ultimately and I'm thinking here of our
friends at Extinction Rebellion I think
pantheism might be an interesting
position to consider just to consider as
we try to change our vision of the earth
that we've been exploiting as an inert
set of resources for human comfort
so here goes
part one in 1697 the French intellectual
Pierre Bayo published his historical and
critical dictionary an Eclectic set of
rambling essays about biblical figures
monarchs a couple of Asian Empires and
the author's untrammeled loathing of the
deceased philosopher Baruch Spinoza
calling Spinoza a Jew by birth and
afterwards a deserter from Judaism and
lastly an atheist Bale does not even
take the time to explain the man's
arguments as far as he is concerned even
the quickest glance by the dullest of
humans will reveal that Spinoza's
philosophy surpasses all the
monstrosities and chimerical disorders
of the craziest people who were ever put
away in lunatic asylums
what is this surpassing monstrosity this
chimerical lunacy bail only names it
once as if dwelling on it any longer
might make it contagious
hiding it in a footnote in a subordinate
clause Bale tells us that this insanity
is the notion that mind and body are
just attributes of the same substance a
single mental bodily everything that
Spinoza called God or nature
so here's our monstrosity according to
Spinoza God and nature are the same
thing the universe is what we mean when
we say the word god
unexpected perhaps unorthodox yes
heretical even but why does Pierre Bale
go out of his mind in the face of this
idea and why does he keep calling it
monstrous
according to Michelle Foucault the word
monster means mixture monsters are
mixtures of different species different
Sexes different materials monsters mix
things that ought to be opposed like
this fellow here a manticore with the
body of a lion and the head of a human
in other Renditions manticores also have
the tail of a scorpion and the wings of
a bat like the monster is a patching
together of different parts now as
you've probably heard Western philosophy
and its more sober forms makes Stark
separations between mind and body male
and female the rational and the
irrational light and darkness each of
these is defined by not being its
opposite moreover these oppositions are
unequal the categories on the right are
traditionally subordinated to the
categories on the left the stuff on the
left is better stronger more real
and so the left side includes all the
characteristics we tend to associate
with God while the right includes the
characteristics we associate with world
or creation or nature God is
anthropomorphic it has a kind of
humanoid form unchanging perfect and
masculine while the world is animal
vegetal changing imperfect and feminine
we still talk about mother earth right
so when Spinoza tells us that God is the
world he's making a very big monster by
equating God with matter Spinoza mixes
the changing and the unchanging created
and Creator Divinity and dirt and as
such produces the most monstrous
hypothesis That Could Be Imagined the
most absurd and the most diametrically
opposed to the most evident Notions of
our mind
now this guy bail Peterbilt does tend to
be a cantankerous writer I should
announce that but his essay on Spinoza
is honestly just a riot of
unsubstantiated name-calling in addition
to the repeated charges of monstrosity
Bale dubs Spinoza's teachings absurd
horrible and vile his ethics and
execrable Abomination his metaphysics
poppycock and his
theo-political Treatise he calls
apprenticious and detestable book in a
similar Vein One of Spinoza's
contemporaries wrote that his books had
been forged in Hell by a renegade Jew
and the devil
and it's good right and The Telltale
sign of this forgery is the Diabolical
notion that God and nature are the same
thing this is the position a later
anti-spinosist will derisively name
pantheism okay so etymologically
pantheism means all God Pawn is all in
Greek Theos God
but it's not clear what all God means in
part because pantheism is a polemical
rather than a positive term a flood of
people will say you're a pantheist and
that's absurd but very few say my
Doctrine is pantheist and this is what
that means so we kind of have to patch
it together casually the term pantheism
tends to connote personal or communal
reverence for nature and it's no
accident that Greek mythology gives the
realm of nature to the goat God Pan the
word in Greek actually becomes the same
thing pan and pan
um pan a monstrous mixture of divinity
and amality and Humanity literally
pantheism often erupts in the form of
the goat God himself pan is all over
poetry he tumbles into Renaissance
romantic and Victorian poetry to play
the pipes lounge with Shepherds dance in
caves Chase nymphs and generally put the
pan in pansexual but philosophically
pantheism remains little more than a
limit case the position nearly everybody
wants to avoid but why what's the matter
with pantheism
to begin it might help to address this
question with its opposite namely why is
pantheism so attractive why does it keep
arising such that it needs to be so
constantly denounced might there be
something alluring about this abominable
position
the case of such ambivalence can be
found in the work of the Reverend
Nathaniel Smith Richardson an Anglican
Theologian in a transcendentalist New
England that's just starting to catch
the fervor of spiritualism the whole
region is allegedly raving with
pantheism which Richardson calls a
misguided dangerous anti-intellectual
and even appalling movement at the same
time he says he can see why pantheism
has swept up the young and unchurched
there is a generosity about it he admits
and a kindliness that's captivating the
kindly generosity of pantheism is its
vision of God in all things it's
coloring the whole world Divine as if it
bore in its hand the wand of an
enchanter it's a gorgeous Vision he
admits with a bewitching power
note the feminine and sexualized
language here pantheism is enchanting
bewitching and gorgeous if you've got
the stomach for it you'll see this sexed
up femininity coursing throughout the
entire anti-pantheist genre for example
the Reverend Morgan Dix of Manhattan
warns that men lacking insufficient
education may have been tempted seduced
tainted poisoned by pantheism unawares
similarly Alexis de tocqueville fears
that pantheism ranks among those
philosophies most likely to entice the
human mind in Democratic ages Herman
Melville's Ishmael confesses while
meditating on what he calls the
mysterious Divine Pacific that lifted by
these Eternal swells you needs must own
the seductive God bowing your head to
pan and Melville himself in a
dramatically homoerotic letter to
Nathaniel Hawthorne says that even
though it is flummery
pantheism is is monstrously attractive
to Melville
so there's that word again pantheism is
monstrous because it conflates Opposite
categories God and world and fittingly
it keeps provoking conflated emotional
responses the Monstrous mixture of
creature and creator gives rise to a
monstrous mixture of Attraction and
repulsion of loathing and longing of I
hate this thing but I can't seem to
think about anything else
part two
in her feminist re-reading of Plato's
Cave loose irigurai reminds us of
Western philosophies raging ambivalence
toward women like the Freudian Boy Child
philosophy aims to make its way from the
dark womb space of the Earth to the
father's brilliant ideas from paganism
to monotheism Earth goddess to Daddy God
the many to the one the cave to the sky
women then are the abandoned origin of
philosophy and as such they're a complex
sight of disgust and desire repudiation
and Nostalgia rejection and command as
Edward Saeed and generations of
post-colonial Scholars have demonstrated
a similarly violent ambivalence
motivates Western representations of the
so-called East orientalist literature
both glorifies and vilifies a feminized
and racialized other at once seductive
and repulsive and this is the problem I
think with pantheism it seems to be a
foreign feminine dark colonized Invasion
into the supposedly rational structure
of white European thought
so for example making no effort to hide
his orientalist Panic Richardson's
Treatise Begins by proclaiming pantheism
is the child of the mysterious East as
evidence Richardson imagines a nameless
Indian Sage in some dim and fragrant
Grove or silent Mountain Cavern dreaming
up the Absurd idea that even dark and
earthborn masses are suffused with a
Divine expression of the one animating
Spirit thanks to its radical
egalitarianism Richardson admits
pantheism is a captivating philosophy
the problem is that it threatens to keep
captivating advancing its appalling
movement there's the ambivalence to such
an extent that he says pantheism in
Europe and the West is destined to
become the correlative of Buddhism in
the East God is forbid such pantheist
seduction Richardson insists can only be
counteracted by Christian Orthodoxy
above all things he says let there be a
plain distinct and dogmatic teaching of
the Incarnation of the Eternal Word and
the Caps are all in the original
manuscript
this is a reference of course to the
appearance of God in human form in the
person of Jesus of Nazareth what when
Richardson says we need to Proclaim that
God came into the world as one man he's
saying God is not the whole animal
vegetable mineral world just that one
guy right an occupied Palestine zero-ish
CE
what panics Richardson about the advance
of pantheism is not however the simple
demise of Christendom rather what he
fears above all is a kind of collective
racialized unmanning the conversion in
his words of Rosy Western men into Dusty
earth-bound womanly pseudo Buddhists he
is terrified and short by blurred
distinctions and crossed boundaries of
east and west passivity and activity
femininity and masculinity Earth and God
Darkness and Light so at this point I'd
like to shift from the diagnostic to the
prescriptive if pantheism is reviled
because it threatens the very structure
of Western philosophy religion and
political order then might it be useful
to those of us who seek to destructure
such orders
here again are some of the foundational
hierarchies of Greek Roman French German
and English metaphysics
now if you're the product of any
remotely feminist or post-colonial D
Colonial materialist queer ecological or
critical race Theory you are bored to
death looking at this slide
but as British philosopher of religion
Grace Jansen began to argue in the late
1990s the reason this structure still
won't budge is that we haven't yet
managed to destroy its root which again
is to say the opposition between God and
World in rejecting this most basic
distinction pantheism rejects the
hierarchies it undergirds
so in this sense one could argue that
pantheism is more radical than atheism
because it changes the meaning of the
word god
rather than a singular anthropomorphic
masculine all-powerful immaterial Force
who either does or doesn't exist
pantheism would suggest that God means
multiplicity
cosmomorphism right rather than
anthropomorphism multiple genders
relational power and a promiscuous
embodiment in all things therefore
Jansen concludes if philosophy wants to
be feminist it's going to have to be
pantheist
the argument is straightforward it's
fairly well known lots of people read
Jansen and yet I cannot think of a
single scholar who has taken up this
call rather pantheism and Western
thought continues to be denigrated by
philosophers and theologians of nearly
every school and political persuasion
from the Orthodox to the heretical
Liberals to liberationists eco-feminists
to christo-capitalists whatever it is we
say we are we are not by any means
pantheists to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit iai.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas